hello everyone I recently returned from
the world government summit in Dubai
where I was pleased to launch a
partnership between the United Arab
Emirates and the World Bank Group to
host an annual platform for education in
this rapidly changing world children
need to be critical thinkers who develop
a lifelong thirst for knowledge and
problem-solving teachers are the heroes
who can equip them to seek analyze and
effectively use information in this
interconnected world children need to
experience and understand other cultures
teachers can play a critical role in
promoting respect and understanding
helping them become better citizens we
know that nothing is possible without
our teachers those of you on the front
line working tirelessly every day to
give our children a brighter future at
the World Bank Group we recognize the
transformational role that teachers play
in shaping children's lives that's why
we support the recruitment and training
of teachers everywhere from India to
Tanzania from Pakistan to Mongolia I've
been lucky to have some great teachers
throughout my life from Elementary
School in the Midwest of the United
States to my professors in medical
school in graduate school I still
remember the lessons I learned from many
committed inspired educators I remain
grateful to all of them I'd like to
extend my gratitude to His Highness
Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid Al Maktoum
thank you for your support of the
teaching profession the patronage of
this prize and your continued efforts to
promote peace and tolerance many thanks
also to the Varkey foundation for your
commitment to education in every corner
of the world it is my honor and pleasure
to announce the ten finalists for the
2017 global teachers prize they are
Salima Begum from Pakistan dahveed kaya
from Spain Rehman chambers from the
United Kingdom where Merson de Silva
Nogueira from Brazil Murray Chris
komari Jeremy from Germany Tracy and
Hall from Jamaica
Maggie MacDonell from the Canadian
Arctic
ken cylburn from Australia Michael Wow
Maya from Kenya and boy a young from
China congratulations to each of you
thank you for your hard work patience
and dedication and I want to say an
additional thank you to dedicated
teachers all over the world
you